In China's central Hunan Province
this month, demonstrators chant,
Give me my money back.
One poster
reads, America, Silicon
Valley Bank
customers
got their money back in three days.
But China's Hunan Village
bank's customers
haven't been given a cent in a year.
So what these protesters
are victims of a banking scandal
that started last April,
when several
small banks in Honan froze
depositor funds,
impacting an estimated 400,000 customers,
according to a state run magazine.
And crucially, some depositors, myself
included, can no longer survive
because all of our money is stored there.
Some people may commit suicide.
Some depositors may hurt others.
Everyone has a tipping point, which
this banking victim
in Beijing is a lawyer
who is gathering depositors
to sue the local authorities.
He says all they want
is their money back,
but instead
they're being tracked, harassed
or even worse.
While the banks are now open
for business,
an estimated several thousand
still cannot access their money.
The banks and authorities have ignored
the victim's relentless efforts
to get answers over the past year.
We're not
revealing the
identities of all the victims
who spoke to us in order
to protect their safety.
What's the limit on the issue?
This couple in Shanghai says earlier
this year
the government
hired people
to stake outside of their apartment
for weeks.
You
know, on March 4th,
right before China's
biggest annual
political meeting in Beijing,
they say their car was suddenly stopped
on the streets of Shanghai.
They were driving to meet a relative
and shot this encounter on a phone.
I want to get in our car.
The man in the brown jacket demands
no, she replies.
So many people have surrounded us.
What are you trying to do?
She asks.
The couple says the men then
threw black cloth bags over their heads
and drove them to an island
outside of Shanghai.
We were locked up for 11 days.
They illegally detained us
and confiscated our bank
cards, phones and wallets.
I tried my best to cooperate with them.
Still, they beat me.
He says the authorities were paranoid.
They might travel
to Beijing to demonstrate
during the political meeting.
The banks, regulators
and local
authorities have not responded
to CNN's
multiple attempts
to contact them about this
serious allegation.
Last summer, police violently
crushed peaceful demonstrators,
demanding their money back.
Then, weeks later,
authorities blamed the scandal
on financial fraud.
Arrested hundreds of alleged suspects
and promised to start paying depositors
back.
China's media has reported
that the government
has the crisis under control
but has ignored the stories
of these bank victims.
Meanwhile, pro Communist Party
social media influencers
have been zeroing in
on the bank failures in the U.S.
This one says explosive news.
The U.S. is facing a catastrophe.
Another says
it might be the end of the U.S.
if they fail to handle this well.
Queen and state
tabloid Global Times
published this dramatic infographic,
but the US government quickly
stepped in to pay back
the depositors in full.
Have you received any sympathy,
any response from the authorities?
Male No, I have not.
The government's attitude
is that as long as they've suppressed
the people with problems,
there's no need to pay back.
The money
is completely different
from how Silicon Valley Bank was handled.
Answer this depositor from Jang Province
went to the protests last
summer and says he was beaten
by the police
and also wanted to see
I can't get the money soon.
Then my children
and I can only live on the streets.
Do you have hope that you're going
to get your money back?
Woman
The people like us
have been robbed of money,
yet we are treated like criminals.
If my money cannot be withdrawn,
only one option is left for me,
which is death.
I go to school back in Beijing.
The lawyer says his relentless
legal efforts may be their only hope.
If you do get the money back,
what is your plan
to leave the country
with kids and parents?
Because I want my children
to grow up in a democratic,
free and rule of law country.
Selina This is amazing.
Great people
wait a year
and still can't get their money.
And, you know, from
from your reporting,
I understand
experts think this bank may
just be the tip of the iceberg.
And how big could this crisis really be?
Well,
Aaron, one
professor of
Chinese business told me
that he estimates
one third or one quarter of China's
small banks are in trouble.
But we may not know how this is spreading
because the government
is getting better
at covering up
and preventing these kinds of leaks.
Now, the root problem here is China's
slowing economy and ballooning debt.
A lot of these small banks
relied on financial products
tied to the real estate sector.
So when the property
bubble burst and China's
economy slowed, well, funds dried up.
And experts
say what we're seeing is Beijing
willing to oppress people
rather than pay the remaining victims
to tell the banking system
they cannot play
fast and loose with money.